hello
welcome everybody we are going to be
playing call of duty black ops 3 zombie
mode and some other awesome online co-op
activities today probably campaign
uh we're currently getting set up a
little bit um
you know
we're the game's not out yet and we're
still figuring it out we still have uh
one person still to get back into the
campaign but we are going to start
anyway and get three people
on online co-op to play zombie mode
zombies
yep this is black ops 3 zombies uh i
haven't had as much experience as you
have mike but you've been playing this a
lot at events and such yeah so tell me a
little bit about what we're what we're
doing here yeah so is it the shadows of
evil map there will be more down the
road as dlc but this is kind of the most
expansive so far i mean they kind of
up the ante so to speak with everyone
like back with black ops 1 black ops 2
with the bus but this is kind of like a
noir 1940s
jazz
really weird there's like there's hp
lovecraft monsters in it it's it's more
complex than any of the other ones but
um yeah once you get into it it starts
yeah i want you guys to get into it yeah
getting super and uh yeah let's go back
a couple times
and then do uh
yeah it should be priced private game
yeah star game started right into it and
uh there are a lot of like big-name
voice actors there's jeff goldblum he's
the biggest i believe ron ron pearl
heather graham
uh roller girl and then um neil
mcdonough he was in band of brothers
right so in medical investigation which
is how you use like my minority report
yeah he's kind of like a
b actor that you see pretty often in
movies yeah he also kind of looks like
um
paul walker in this little frame right
or like um who's the star trek kirk the
new guy what's his name he's pretty
[ __ ] fine chris pine kind of looks
like responding yeah
with a mistake here at least in this
loading screen why can't he be his own
person why why do you have to compare
him because he's just not good enough
yet
you know once you're a-list yeah then
people compare others to you
he sure was the rock smoked him with a
2x4 all right so yeah i would suggest
getting a gun right away because the
revolver more so than ever
the 38 you start with is pretty useless
everyone is talking at once
yeah they're all just
they all have funny little quips and
jokes because they all have backstories
right so right so one of them is like a
magician and one of them is a
you know like one of them i believe is a
hooker or whatever and they'll like make
jokes or at each other or blame each
other for the expense like so they'll
say stuff like
like oh is this one of your magic tricks
gone wrong is this your fault
there's and there was a trailer trailer
that was released and it kind of hinted
that each one of these each of these
four people
did something really sinful like jeff
goldblum i guess his wife
like did something with insurance or she
they were in debt and so he killed her
oh um
the cop is crooked
uh i think the hooker he killed a guy
killed a guy in bed or something so you
can see i just turned into this cthulhu
thing um
that's new don't get that insta kill
that recharges but yeah i'm so yeah
that's not normal you can also hit these
things which are pretty
um we're also because you get money per
board uh you can let the zombies kind of
take a few boards down
and then kill them and that way you get
the extra money for the board so uh
mike what is this what is this like
thing right here on this truck okay so
you pick these up and they're summoning
keys which i have not gotten far enough
to know what they do i know where you
put them okay but yeah you collect those
over the course those are kind of like
the metagame that a lot of the zombies
maps have um the cthulhu pretty much
anything you see glowing with these
weird glyphs on it you have to be that
cthulu thing
you can also charge up the quick revive
machine right here with it which i just
forgot to do so that was my fault but we
should probably go through this door up
here no there's a detriment when you're
cthulu though right yeah you don't
uh make money with for kills so it's a
good last resort or for actually solving
the puzzles but
if you're trying to get better weapons
it's not your best bet
and you also get um
grenades
per
yep per round as well uh it's not
is it per round i think well
every so as far as other zombies you you
stock up on grenades every so each round
you get two grenades is what i remember
right i could be wrong i think it's
changed over the over the course of
the series of zombies the main thing i
use them for is um kind of uh
jibbing the last zombie to make it crawl
so you can kind of are you're free to go
around exploring we should probably go
through this door now we're in round
four okay
so yeah let's all go
um actually we should go through is this
kind of like the old ones where you guys
probably might have wanted to conserve
ammo there a little bit and just like
knife some of those easy guys uh you
can't so you can such a big deal i found
that this revolver is even like more
worthless than the old colt 45 okay and
then knifing is still i'm gonna go get
that insta kill everyone so like the
revolt like you would think eric like i
know we played uh exo zombies like you
want to hold on to your guns yeah i used
to use your money but sorry rob use your
knifes or pistols right now he's got
insta kill oh i didn't notice um um yeah
but
the revolver that you start with is
garbage it is yeah like it just doesn't
do anything
gotcha
i need like an auto
so there are a lot of different ways you
can go you go to canal district the
waterfront um i like the waterfront
because it leads to something pretty
cool i'm gonna get this nuke it's about
to disappear uh [ __ ]
um yeah you guys are gonna save guys
let's try to do this we have not
successfully saved a guy all right
don't kill him i said
forget it did we did we i no oh no
there's still one more hold on hold on
all right yeah no one kills no one can
kill these guys all right
there's still three grenades okay i got
one i got one oh so we just
i didn't know we threw here all right
are we not killing this guy don't kill
anyone kill that one i'm gonna get this
there's still a couple more
damn
all right we're gonna see it all right i
got one nice so kill anything you see
except for this crawling one
they also crawl it's kind of freaky
like a grudge kind of guy's just hanging
out now all right so we got a crawler
you guys want to go to that um
shot he looks good though
um
so okay looks like freddie cruz let's
let's go to the waterfront we can go to
the um the slip space portal which i'm
not kidding there is one
you know let's go this way
yeah the portals are really interesting
uh it changes the environment completely
yeah you go i haven't i've yet to figure
out if the places you warp to are
actually connected physically as well
yeah so the idea is that you want to
establish
in all zombies you want to establish a
loop
like a path that you can essentially run
down and hose zombies as you walk
backwards and also portal is i'm
assuming is is basically that part part
of that path right like right um
yeah from what i've learned so the magic
box can be right there we saw that last
night um so that's the portal right
there it kind of looks like bioshock
infinite actually um
i don't know where the crawler is a real
ugly bioshock
hey
all right whoa are the zombies on their
way uh no
oh yeah because we got this guy just a
heads up if you guys ever are the
cthulhu it when you run out of the meter
you respawn back at the
which is not good for the next round
because i think the next round is the
bats is it not correct and those things
if you're alone are pretty brutal so are
you all good with i'm gonna get another
weapon well i guess we could like i mean
we should probably take i want to take a
slow shot we put up any board see like
some of these like zombie
uh spawn points like don't have the
ability to put up boards which is weird
yeah so this so this spot right here we
found last night actually we were
holding out for a while because then
once you open the portal
which is free the rift as it's called
one person could just watch this window
the other two just kind of shoot down
the alley
but
it helps the portal once you go through
it becomes even more complicated there's
different stairways
yeah and you're in a completely
different environment so all of a sudden
all the rules of where the zombies come
from changes up and
right so here's the actually before that
zombie dies because i think we're
running out of time so what
what is oh yeah gobblegum so
people played zombies will probably like
recognize the quick revive machine
or uh right here you have staminup which
they're kind of just giving you
different abilities when you drink them
before you get down
gobblegum is like a preset custom one
that you can do uh before if you saw on
the menu we all had like the colored
options they
you have to obviously i'll do it right
now i don't care
do it so i get one and it gives you a
random one just like real change so i
got plain sight i'm coming over and i
just ate it so
you can activate it later so that i'll
be ignored by zombies for 10 seconds
which is pretty huge if i'm trying to
escape wow um
but that it only lasts until your next
uh down got it so you guys want to kill
a zombie and okay well can we establish
like is this what's our next move as far
as like waypoint uh like making that
loop what's our goal here so i would say
let's hold out here for a little bit to
make more money right in this alley and
then go through the rift when we get
overwhelmed because then we go down
there and it's a little more that expand
where did that lady go so i'll open it
up right now have it open but don't walk
through it
i mean you can if you want oh it's on
it's happening oh come back here she
must have died
oh it's the bats right
i think it is because it's around yeah
let's go back that was weird
let's back up and i can't remember it
defensible area
yellow if it's the bats
they're really gross
oh still
uh yeah get that insta kill uh mary okay
uh everybody use knives or your
shittiest weapon you have
how long is this good for the insta
behind you um the the skull at the
bottom of your screen will start to
flash and it'll tell you when it's
running out okay
just stabbing zombies
rob are you good on that back one dad oh
you know it dude all right i got a
couple points covered
all right it's about to run out everyone
so just keep that in mind nice
buster those little they have double
damage yeah double damage is worth that
all right
so um that's so hot this should be the
bats once we kill the bats do you wanna
so if anybody keeps hearing about this
bat reference uh there are dogs and
hounds in previous versions
now it's these flaming weird bug things
they're disgusting and annoying they're
easy to kill but they overwhelm you they
remind me of that what's that starcraft
zerg the flying ones
yeah yeah that kind of remind me of that
oh [ __ ] they're kind of stuck in this
alley by myself
come in the room with the riff they
can't like oh i'll get you
take care of the
bugs yeah i got it i kind of like them
oh [ __ ]
i don't know what your problem is i
think they're great
i'm gonna give one to my son they like
nice
all right um through the portal now you
want to go check that out through the
part
we should probably wait half a round
right okay and then just escape through
it yeah i mean we had this on lockdown
because my weapons are not quickly
becoming pretty i was killing it over
here
i forgot how good we're at this game
loadout right now i've got don't you
forget it you're the lowest level though
aren't you huh i think you're the lowest
level me lowest level out of the three
of them well i don't know what the
there's no level i mean there's money
okay oh the emblem
the threes
who didn't make it me
oh no we need him
um he's our trump card oh [ __ ] i should
have used the uh ignore me for 10
seconds
sorry sorry i was in the zone
oh god just go back to the portal and
just keep looping through it so what
portal oh that's the one you came from
it's like you guys knew that the
fourth game
here that we have was up
we had a breakdown in communication oh
sweet so we can get a fourth person in
now
help us out so let's do that so our
mistake there
was that i died very
quickly and i had an ability i'm still
not used to having gobble gum because
that would've helped to be ignored for
10 seconds and kind of run around when
do you how do you eat it yeah how do you
once you uh buy them from the machine
you press down when you want to use it
down
yeah good to know all right so uh if you
guys want to go to a main menu just
press x mary the gobblegum is new to me
no never mind it'll just go through yeah
it's it takes getting used to
remembering you have that option
um so
now
eric you can join um mary's party it's
gonna be rob actually
try and join our irish axe
give me a hot second here okay
we can uh
yeah it takes a good i'll show you
explain some of these gobblegums for me
so many that you can unlock because i
don't understand it's essentially
another loadout so right here this is my
loadout right now and you see i have
coagulant arms grace but then you can
customize it and you go into the blue
ones which they're all in categories i
don't know how they separate them but
then you have i haven't unlocked a lot
as you can see
but
um you also have megas which are kind of
like burner ones that you have to
actually collect
and so they're obviously much more
powerful this just spawns a nuke power
up which is pretty helpful
um this key you keep all the perks you
get from the colas after being revived
so these are all ones that are helpful
if you get far into the game
which i use and these are all unlocked
through play
yeah oh so there's like a completely
different uh progression system
so uh
i'm not
so you see
so you have weapon kits and everything
so these are the ones that you can
actually sound like the bowie knife but
you then you actually upgrade the
separate weapons and everything some
machine guns here these are the
different ones you can get from the
magic box and on the wall
um there's a lot more actual
character progression this time around
in zombies okay so we have four people
let's do it um
uh yeah so let's start game
all right let's do it so how are you um
how would you essentially unlock these i
mean it's just experience overall yeah
so i'm at level five i think on my
profile
it's not showing it right now but yeah
you just you get different there's
different challenges uh each weapon has
challenges it's essentially the
multiplayer progression in zombies and
also call of duty black ops 3 has
progression in campaign you have
different loadouts we can show that in a
little bit i think we might get into it
um right so i mean i even saw the you
know one of the big things about call of
duty is you can you know customize your
guns with blacksmith or gunsmith excuse
me uh but you can will those transfer
over i'm curious about that they don't
transfer over but it does have its own
like camouflage paint
progression in zombies okay so it's
separate it's the same thing but it's
separate yeah they're not
the same system but it's not connected
yeah so it's its own it's if you're the
person who buys black ops just for
zombies you will have your own
experience separate from the campaign
multiplayer progression
yeah so i'm stuck loading that's awesome
all
right
started loading oh geez well you look
you look like you're
like an action hero
oh no you're blinking paused in the game
okay anyway nope i just saw almost you
guys i watched you disappear
okay
sick we could die and then well let me
see there's no there's no is there drop
in i don't know actually let's try that
try it and if not we'll die we're going
to die anyway it's not like it makes a
difference it'd be pretty sweet if there
was drop in you could be like a wave 15
and really need someone
but i don't know if there is
okay so i just hit level
oh foiled with three never mind the
lobby is not joinable okay
is it because it's on private
it's not on private it's open well you
have
let's have to try it again next time
hey who the [ __ ] is talking do you know
what's going on
that's how we get things done in this
department so later on you trigger
something that lets you go up these back
stairs and i was telling mary this
morning that there are
a lot of upper levels that i i've seen a
bunch but not all of them whatsoever
oh uh
rob come hit this crate on the back of
the truck when you get the chance behind
you
wait you didn't get it
no melee
uh mainly r3 got it there you go i am so
good at this so now we got this
summoning key we could try i know where
the next one is it's just we keep i keep
forgetting to get it um it's like a
fountain pen the next one
all right so we're on round three when
do we want to leave i'd say let's do
finish this round and then go what's the
fumigator again that lets you uh this
pod over here
you like the pods i forgot how you how
they phrase it but you you use it on
this pod and then it just spawns a power
up okay because if you shoot the pod it
spawns a zombie right so yeah use the
fumigator on it
building barriers
keeping out the zombs hey lady
come on in dude
oh you're not dead nuke heads up
okay yeah let's go through the door
some of the things they say is actually
pretty funny i love when jeff goldblum
he sounds like jfk he says like time
waits for no man
actually that was more of a jfk
impersonation but he does sound like
that i heard a little bloom
let's uh i just opened the door so heads
up
you got uh some zombies you gotta uh uh
some some some zombies so i prefer to
just go through another door right now
because
this courtyard sucks to defend if you
want to try another route or go toward
that riff
yeah sorry i got max ammo so we can't
join you i know i'll just wait okay all
right
shotgun please so uh you guys you want
to go to the footlight district
i have the money it smells like feet
though
oh my god what
there's another gobblegum machine behind
you mary sorry i was looking at the
train trap
granada
so this area's new huh yeah see there
are a lot of okay so here's the cthulhu
door i can do that now actually while
things are kind of slow
or does someone else want
mary why are you trying to look no
oh god it's insta-kill and yeah got it
oh i threw a grenade by accident sorry
yeah let's try to get a crawler once the
insta kill wears off so we can look
around here
yeah we'll save it let's save it dude
i'll get right i'll give it a whirl okay
we'll save this so we see someone else i
see someone else kills her all right
that's a good gun mary it's got a pretty
high rate of fire hey babe oh i lied so
yeah once
wait hold on i want to make sure that's
not the last guy yeah don't don't kill
him oh yeah kill him kill him
also insta kill's about to run out
don't kill this one that's chasing me
i'm gonna limp it
you're doing god's work mike
run
gotta get it [ __ ]
no i missed all right oh i got another
grade
you guys do your thing what what's that
got him all right we got a crawler so i
feel like also like the bubble gum
machines are more of a later game thing
like we should be getting actual perks
right like that's kind of how like
originally i would play especially
because a lot of the gobblegum effect
like you'll have your perks when you
revive so in order to maximize the
randomness i'm going to do the cthulhu
quick don't kill that crawler just oh
god you scared me okay
so here's the door i wonder if there's a
rip through oh there's a zombie oh it
it's mine i found another rift
okay but anyway
let's see what else i could do while i'm
here
okay so i found like an actual what is
this
what's going on
sweet so
oh the crawler's gonna be right next to
me when i spawn
okay
oh wait why did uh i think we respawned
and killed it what are we doing right
now let us i just opened this thing let
us prepare for the next round of zombs i
think it is the next round isn't it
yeah that's the next round
oh that was oh we're in it i guess so oh
so this brings us back oh no damn you
can tell because the music from like the
1940s begins
yeah or 20s so just here's where
the 40s yeah
the great depression really i see
flappers that's the only reference i
have
so uh the rift if you guys want to try
to move over this way we have the
rift over here
there's a bunch behind you rob i know i
don't i know i feel like that's a really
obvious thing to say no it's no
no it's always worth a heads up
there's a crawl alert
oh i killed him
[ __ ] i mean could open up this door or
what i got him yeah i did um go through
the portal i'm down i'm down
if you can possibly just keep running in
circles and
that sounded like i was being sarcastic
but
you can kind of lead them on a chase and
then revive one oh i'm down no that's
risky but now i'm down wait oh
lord yeah don't don't revive me just go
through the rift or no oh [ __ ] yeah tell
me what to do do the riff do the rift
good lord
oh god i'm never going to survive you
want to go back through it no no no no
from there
hey rob
[ __ ]
we did we did pretty well we did not
all right
now we have four we're getting tan
so as you can see it's pretty huge there
are like we've probably seen a court not
even a quarter maybe a quarter of the
whole map yeah it looked like there's a
whole like street like broadway street
right there's another parking garage and
movie theater pest i've been to the
movie theater it's pretty sweet that's a
good spot i've seen that too it's a good
hold up because they're coming up the
aisles we should try that next time yeah
well that's the thing
it's just getting
those loops like
see so i just unlocked a couple
progression things
oh right
all right let's kick it off we're all
here i'm gonna start a game
hold on to your butts
i'm holding on
hold it good thing
i have a good feeling about this one
i don't i don't either actually so i'll
go ahead and feel it sums
you don't have a good day today thursday
morning i was actually slaying just now
until rob was like hey
sorry was i interrupting somebody
i saw someone get a sparrow shut down
kill that kill your power
okay
so
don't build them
if all goes well i'll have
uh i won't freeze this time and just
like blink the whole time oh no
no i thought you were faster that time
this could be good let's go come on mary
is the host she'll take the longest if i
don't go i'm taking you with me
oral passage all right all right
it worked great scott we're family now
good job everyone
now let's make it past round five
i still don't know these guns yet like
shiva does anyone know what kind of gun
that is uh it's a submachine gun
of some sort
shiva is a single shot isn't it yeah
it's a single shot i have no idea it's
like a i want to say that shiva's like
that foul
he's running get out of here anybody
want you just like the window
do this thing i have no points you don't
get any
take those boards hey get out of here
yeah so
it's pretty helpful to let them tear
down the boards and then
i just want some points oh here's some
things
wandering hands that's just something
hookers say
it's her catchphrase
anybody wanna die
what uh what's your characters what are
the characters names
no not that person
mike finds a way i love crafting it
bam
i'm gonna charge the quick okay so if
wants quick quick revive before we leave
this area that i just charge that nah
that's a stupid perk okay
it's true i was trying to be a dick i
just that's like the like the one i
always never get i don't want to kill
anybody because i want to make money
because i never go down yeah okay so
there's max m over here in this room and
it doesn't it's not time so let's leave
that until we really need it
oh next year
next to me
i didn't do that oh actually it was
awesome
so the fountain pen is in the next
courtyard
in case you were wondering and curious
so we need all of the summoning keys to
do something that we don't know
so
something triggers these stairs back
here we go up there and there's this
altar you sacrifice them at
and i don't know what it does correct
but i'm sure it's cool
but
i'll tell you this i'm sure it's weird
as [ __ ] just like the rest of this
shadows of evil
really fun nonsense okay
yeah i was there don't give me that look
everyone wants money i want money
this is a team effort let me get my
money and then you can have a team of
effort it's the trickle down effect when
i'm rich
i will give some of my richness to you
who's jeff goldblum right now me turco
yeah you want to open the door for us
after this round not really i got a dude
sure i'll do it cause i'm loaded no i
don't know who way it's not me someone
else who's got 21. i'm getting max ammo
everybody reload
see not only am i not getting all the
farm i need i have to open the door wait
wait wait didn't rob definitely have
more money there nope i didn't boy now i
do
okay
so
i really like to get out of this
courtyard
let's get out of courtyard what say we
do anybody want to open the uh foot
light district again no not really here
where is it i'll open that too right
here from team player over here just
you're just gonna rock the revolver the
whole day the whole damn time
you're gonna become such a liability
swallow your words and i'm gonna laugh
yeah but who else was gonna open the
door there nobody else this game is
bothering a part
all right
who wants to let's try to get a crawl
out of this round so we can oh you're
you already took the beast rob come here
i'm a beast get this box get this box
quick okay oh my melee
and then come over here you got to get
the riff door open where's that past
these zombies okay
oh i'm keep going down watch out behind
damn it whoever
son of a [ __ ] uh are you still cthulhu
can you revive us quick uh [ __ ] come on
you two hold out oh [ __ ] oh my god all
right i got one okay sweet well you're
just gonna leave me no i got you maybe
there's there's zombs dude i got you
[ __ ] i didn't i didn't care i still went
i saw it did you open the rift door do
we want to leave this crawler or what
yeah he would kill you got that rift
he's crawling
oh okay so kill this guy because he's
not crawling wait oh we already have a
crawler there's a crawler behind yeah
kill this one there all right can i open
this uh yeah go for it there's another
there's a runner kill the runner kill
that too oh it's fun out here hey
dancing in this go towards yeah so leave
the crawler civil protector offline crap
i need ammo oh
great this is a huge open area
yeah well you have three thousand
and see macaroos let's let's not
count money that's not what makes you
happy
two minutes ago
you were the richest hello and pedantic
who was the first one to get down
uh it wasn't me though i don't think it
was you was it okay what's the screen
button maybe i wouldn't have gotten down
if i had you guys want to call the train
how about we uh
okay that's creepy who wants to go on a
train ride
i like trying that okay
don't make me keep saying training yeah
let's go let's listen well why don't we
start the round and then get on the
train
well let's explore as much as we can
before
the crawler all right let's get started
all right train wait a minute
oh look it it's jeff goldblum's
character anyway
um i'm calling the truth i'm famous what
if you had a power you could turn us
into kids and then we live in a loft
okay all right i'm calling trying and
dance on keyboards all right
did you do it
yes it's a little inside joke it
happened to me once
are you talking about the movie big no
oh wait yeah actually it sounds familiar
to my
real life these references are
ridiculous i'm calling the train yeah
call the train
the train is moving
all right let's get on all aboard
canals oh there's different switches for
okay show me to shoot it um no
canals oh it's all just canals that make
sense make up choice one stop we're
gonna be stuck in here with this guy oh
wait oh no hurry he's not he's gonna go
he's trying to get one
oh can he not kill him he's stuck all
right wait canelo
wait lure him off first let me learn him
off and then press the button don't you
[ __ ] leave me because i know you're
thinking everybody everybody learn off
i don't know i kind of like them
i want to keep them let's let's leave
them on everyone just do it
all right all right let's go back down
all right go button press the button go
oh he's coming he's coming again
to press bring him on oh wait now do you
not have enough money he's coming no
he's coming with us
we're gonna take him on a ride
oh look he loves it
he's like yeah i love the chain
rob can we get you some smooth skin
voice
hey there guys
where are we going first
got any lotion [ __ ]
i'm gonna get on his level
no
hey there
give me a kiss
give me a kiss
come on all right we have arrived oh oh
god we're at the canals now
sorry there's a map of the place
we're gonna be late let's go so there
are three stations is he coming up
behind me you're damn right kind of but
i want to get can we do do we have any
leashes
you want to go what's through here
let's go into the damn high street this
is huge all right new door okay up here
i just opened one
that's my uncle
all right he was in hell are we not
killing that guy oh no
mystery box down here huh oh sweet
mystery box down there
oh yeah there's if you go to the left
there was a way down
past this crawler
where i'm at some sort of
strip club wow uh we are separating i
have to open up this gate do you want me
to do that
to get to the mystery box oh wait i
don't have enough money
who's uh who's heather graham's
character it's me but i don't have
enough money
i need a hundred more dollars we've been
kind of waiting to pick up like money
everywhere pick up the phone also i'm a
hooker oh i i got one i'd like to be
rewarded okay
i got one fuse where'd you go i'm in
character i don't end character until we
roll the credits
over this way don't knife me
i am well then what's the problem oh my
good one
mary you said you know what door we have
to go through did you get something well
no i thought i thought we'd go through
here to open up that rift that's what i
thought all right
i don't know down below does anyone have
a snack
have you guys seen uh down below i don't
have any cookies oh my god
oh yeah you can get the little guy this
way
come over here give me a kiss
oh
i feel like you didn't think this
through give me a little kiss
you know what i'm going rogue i'm about
to shoot him so he could actually kills
off yeah this is getting this is getting
this is ridiculous oh
hey we're just having fun we're
exploring you should have let me kill
him because then i'd have enough money
to open that gate
okay yeah yeah so this door right here
look alive wait everybody let's back up
against this door because they can't
come behind us
oh like that you mean all right i have
enough money am i going no one is yes
let's just defend from that's just me
here you know don't worry about me
i always got your back dude thanks oh
you guys are so cute
jealous
yeah oh no too close
you know all right we should oh yeah
everybody
oh god i'm down no i'm not i said that
prematurely
turco i got you
okay i still have a goddamn revolver so
do i
remove our life revolving
[ __ ] what was that oh carpenter knife
knife
all right should i somebody shouldn't
have killed [ __ ] round six is dinosaurs
everybody can i open it
oh yeah mary open it let's go get the
mystery box up and at it mystery bar
over this way over this way oh it's to
the left right oh it's bats oh no it's
bad everybody stick together
uh we gotta go down these stairs yeah oh
[ __ ]
oh they're ugly
oh [ __ ] they're coming up
[ __ ]
did you become an old man
i'm covered in acid i'm down you got
benjamin thought it was
oh [ __ ] me and you rob
don't yeah yeah yeah
i ran to safety all right we're coming
oh hey go figure whoa
that's how we healed
didn't we want to keep it alive uh those
ones aren't as easy to keep wait around
well the box is down here right all
right where are we going see what we get
let's get some if it gives me like a
revolver i'm going to
wait is it only for one person wait how
the hell is this machine gun all right
wait how'd you guys get pretty good a
boat's a boat but a box could be
anything it could even be about rob over
here
should i open the mystery box staircase
are we going back up the stairs uh i'm
waiting for rob i'd like us to commit to
a plan you know what i'm good i'm good
don't worry about me who's gonna buy use
the mystery box no it's all right oh
crap guys obviously there's max amazon
we didn't need it but all right looks
i think we should be doing something
like leaving
oh that's all right mike you're
appointed leader of this
okay okay ragtag green group of idiots
so i'm gonna need you to like make a
choice here let's hold up oh they jump
in that i've got a pretty heavy duty
machine gun
that's not important though what's it
it's a burst machine gun that's weird i
don't care what are we doing uh let's
just kill them for now let's come back
up these stairs right here
they're behind us too
we're gonna die come back get up here
we're ryan
hold on hold on i'm crawling to you guys
yeah you're done oh no i can crawl oh
i'm gonna make it hey if you want to
revive it yeah i'm working on it
i think we're all right
i spoke too soon
we could go back to the train uh you
want to ride the train again kind of
yeah let's try the train again
they just spawned oh i love trains [ __ ]
yeah let's go train
go up the train canal station yep
i'm getting really familiar with the
train systems
where are we going uh footlight or spawn
go to the waterfall all right get in
there they're spotted get in then
uh mary can you activate it over there
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait is that in stuff who is
i made a call
it was the best one but it worked in the
end
all right so we're good oh there's a gun
right here if you need a bootlegger
bootlegger it's like 2 000 though that's
probably good you got you have to do
something i know but i'm going to keep
it so that somebody can open doors
i think 1200 i'm going to keep the train
fare going
why
we're just wasting money we gotta make
money make money money heck
you kill zombies you ride the train
kills zombies right now do they spawn
here now yeah they kind of oh [ __ ] we
gotta get down here guys like this is
where we're gonna get stuck because
they're all ready come on let's go down
the stairs
they're behind us too
we are now trapped in this stairwell
i'm down if you can ah
hey do we all die yeah being in an alley
is no so here's what's key right is
she stayed on the train no no
when you take the train you get the hell
out of the train station because that
was a bottleneck with four people i feel
like the two doors on the train would be
easy to defend because that's you have
your back up to something instead of
just a stairwell i mean to a degree but
i feel like you can get overwhelmed
yeah i think exploring was it i'm pretty
happy wonderful we got to know the map a
little more
definitely
so there are two other maps though right
this
it's like dlc down the road oh this is
the only map shadows of evil is the only
one right now oh i thought there was a
another map there's like a playstation
exclusive one coming later on gotcha all
right one last time okay and then
campaign co-op and i guess
i don't know level four that just felt
like such a poor performance
i felt like a what your poor performance
is
zombies though
uh maybe i was still first
in score all right let's start again
let's do it again
today when real zombies start killing us
i don't think score matters and that's
kind of pretty sure i would have ran
away with rob and we would have found
some [ __ ] wait why would rob why are you
leaving me behind why are you even
married behind because he's the only one
that you alive
deal with it dude all right we're gonna
get married okay
i hope there actually is an apocalypse
so i can prove a point and just not it's
all right just not care about you that's
fine i'm gonna hold it's like zombieland
i have the stamina i just need to get a
shotgun
and then you know it'll be fine i'm
gonna ride the train by myself and i'm
gonna have a great time
seems to be a good way of avoiding
zombies
it's been falling apart okay
hey eric
let's just hang out
okay cool
oh my god
marty it's me if [ __ ] goes down yeah
it's me and you
you have my back
i don't trust rob
you shouldn't rob to just stab you in
the back the second he can that's fine
why are you trying to totally true break
my trust with him i just
i'm not i'm preparing
yeah
whoa
revolver is fine you just gotta get
headshots
oh i'm the hooker now
oh god what is happening what is mike
who am i connection mike look at me tell
me who i am you
are who am i guess i can see it in the
lower you're the detective neil
mcdonough dude oh who cares
[ __ ] compton
all right hooker or goldblum all the way
connection is being very weird
transmogrification
yeah you have
more network connectivity problems
yeah you got to expect in a zombie
apocalypse that the internet won't be
secure yeah oh there's an insta yeah
just save it hold it
how long do those last
that one specifically in that room
doesn't disappear okay most of the time
it's like
20 seconds
because there was a nuke before that i
was holding out yeah and then it
disappeared yeah it starts flashing then
you have another like five seconds to
get it no yeah they'll steadily flash
away
hey baby
tell you look real good
you look okay
i didn't know it was heather graham what
do you like to see right now yeah
i like it put your face down there then
i'll teabag you i don't think you're
allowed to say it
out of context
that's what happens when you get tea
bagged
you can it's not necessarily true man
yeah you're not i don't think girls can
see that it was yeah i don't know
is that the discussion yeah that's
that's not possible yeah
well well
well and we stopped there
you started it
it escalated quickly okay
yeah
all right
my funds are less than i'd like them to
be
yeah you guys are broke because you guys
be not trusting the revolver
see rob knows what's up
you gotta save for the better guns in
the next area that's right dude
maybe i can get a goddamn head shot here
we go
what's up bro
dude
bro
live zombies find your own
did that just auto pick i should have
saved it huh
that's fine um
what does that mean let's do this door
that's a positive
i'm going to rebuild this barrier and
then i'm coming does anybody want to
open the door i mean i'll do it
the junction door yes all right let's go
also let's someone else let's try to get
out of here as soon as possible
going to get a gobblegum
i'm going to get a gobblegum you guys
deal with these zambies always done
swiftly what is this one they give me a
go again there's a guy following him
quicker move faster
not having that max ammo yeah that's
cool i guess me quite a bit
um anybody want to go into the footlight
just no let's go somewhere different
let's go let's go to a new area each
time hold on let's get a crawler here
let's designate someone to be the
crawler maker
i'll i got you covered look out sounds
like the leader is chosen himself
i have the punch uh behind you ty never
mind
killing that okay we got one don't kill
this crawler but kill the walkers oh
okay
hey baby hey baby hang back it takes
three melees right now kill one oh
what happened
i think it spawned as i walked into it
you guys want to take this ammo or
should i leave yeah get that all right
okay the room
the round didn't then all right we got
hold on let's get a crawler on this one
nobody killed it oh nice
oh there's two i'll try to get one of
them
okay
yeah leave the crawlers for now
okay we want duel there's one yeah dub
crawl yeah there are a couple yeah let's
let's give them something
you going to feed them
throw thermal bone
hey baby
so
let's go through
let's go to a new area what's the new
what's an area we haven't been to yet
let's go down i'm going to sewer area
how about the waterfront yeah let's do
waterfront because we can't go down yet
i'll be the guy that opens the door you
guys can no no i can do it give daddy a
kiss i got money i got lots of money
honey all right dude i'm ready
i don't want you hooking no more but i
want you i'm gonna start a new life for
us both oh oh yeah no more hooking that
was pretty it was pre married whatever
last year before it's true
that was your old life baby we're
starting a new you said you wouldn't
you come this way though oh god this
one's not crawling anymore what oh hello
she grew her legs nah it's a girl it's a
miracle wait is this the same one these
are different zombies what the hell
maybe because we went to a new area yeah
sometimes it happens
wait what no maybe those two just grew
their legs once we left no they didn't
they were different people no they did
not i i knew her sunday dress purple not
white i'm going to get the beast to open
the uh to open the rift door
oh no it's bad yeah
i have a really shitty gun for badge i'm
using this change your gun i can't
there's not really an option well i've
got tentacles get a better gun
i'm probably gonna go down here because
i'm in the alleyway where they can
easily shoot me i'm opening the door for
the rift
oh god i'm covered in open acid
lightning bugs from hell time weights
ball no man
oh whoa that thing's levitating you guys
wanna sorry i had to get it i made a
call all right you want me to open this
rift
yeah here we go i'd say let's defend
why can't i
use it all right we meeting in the
alleyway
because they're starting to come on
oh i need another one i only have that
oh there's a insta
over there um it's
not oh i went down i saw that
slowly but steadily good thing you guys
love each other
he was done eric knows that oh don't
worry i'm going to crawl through they
can't get rid of me
oh god did you guys come up here
oh my god i thought oh that's good to
know you can't go through when you're
done i'm alone
why can't i go into the block i'm going
to come to
oh my god rob
you're rob you can you can ride people
that's
run
run up here let's go
oh i'm super out of ammo i think i'm
like dead dead now
yeah you'll come back at the beginning
of the next round oh my god i just have
a revolver this is great i'm fine this
is fine i'm fine whoa this guy is
hovering
what the hell is that yeah stay away
from those witches
yeah yeah give him the old shot he did
the [ __ ] kick their ankles i got some
calls and pleasure
oh he just disappeared got some crowlers
oh i'm gonna get married oh i'll crawl
to you no wait there's people [ __ ] run
no
wait i'm up leave a crawler if possible
okay
no i want to play just just kill
everyone
sweet thank you you got it okay
mystery box is not here either wait am i
dead crawlers yeah you're dead you're
dead
are you able to get married i am dead
yeah i'm gonna kill this one
okay there's two more i can leave them
let them do their thing let's look
around here so you want to get some food
or something yeah
there's a
here this pod's not poisonous eat it
yeah i'm gonna eat it let me all right
what happened what's the plan here a
zombie is gonna come you should probably
get looking for a better weapon on the
wall first yeah i definitely don't want
to be here for too much longer because
these are i don't know what these are
where's that cthulhu thing let me go
find it quick
quickly
over there
i think that's a hole there's this what
is this what are you doing zam's come
out of
uh
well
so i'm not seeing anybody sucks yeah
yeah this is where i live
is there a trail there's another crawler
up here too he's very slow
anything out here
let me just have to open another door
from here i don't know that we can't can
we go back through this
other dude yep okay the portal we'd go
back to the yeah go through the portal
and find a different portal that's more
interesting yeah because i think we're
going to go up here right we need to
come through here as the cthulhu thing
to activate a lot of this stuff okay
what the hell is up here this is just
straight up a dead end
yeah are you kidding me how would you
ever want to go up here
so yeah oh no here's the thing we have
to wait till the end of the round
i don't think it's really staying down
here
i'm just going to get this wow
you want to
yeah all right make a call i don't need
to do anything let's do it actually i'll
get this one the two are about to spawn
wait are those is there still another
one yeah
wow
all right are we going back through that
portal keep in mind all you have are
revolvers right now so you might want to
buy something i never bought anything to
begin with so oh yeah
there's a good gun over here
all right i say we just stand here and
then uh
they're spawning and hold up we're
missing someone no i'm here oh no don't
get that's a new okay i'm waiting yeah
actually just get it i'm really close to
touching it just get it
double the score
double your
pleasure for money
it's never made me happy
do we beat that round
well we've done we've kind of expedited
things no they're going to come still
here they come where you guys going do
you guys want to go through the
we have to
portal now
oh i'm down go through
go through
yep
they're gonna come through the portal
behind us
don't mind me guys i'll just shoot him
in the trunk
i'll just shoot him in the junk
oh i'm out of bullets no come back here
behind you oh there you are
get up sweet baby
get up
let's go
go back wait where are you going back
through the portal oh i'm going oh no no
we're coming to you no no we're coming
yeah we're coming to you okay let's go
back before we came oh it's a kid
do this just spin around circle firing
[ __ ] they're about there they came
through the portal what's that there are
a lot of them coming through the rift i
need them oh my god i just got
do you guys see this thing what is that
giant thing i don't know
i'm dead did you see the giant yeah
monster he looked like a
two-legged
walking robot squid looked like my dad
eight rounds
that's how far we got last time i bet
damn you guys see that score
that's hot
wanna go jump into campaign co-op now
let's do it quick sure let's do a quick
mish
hey you don't seem happy about that
round nah
that's my fault
there was there was a point where you
could have bought a gun there were a few
points where you could have bought many
guns yeah
trying to hold out for that other gun
that i got the last round the hbr
cool uh so mary why don't you uh back
out all right
spring party i'll bring you guys with me
it's a party all right and then go back
out again
okay oh we got to make a character
oh i didn't get to do that i'll choose
my old gender
i think it'll just be automatic okay um
i love all the different options of
short-haired ladies i can pick hair gets
in the way on the battlefield
shave it keep going regular done
all right we all in you want to pick oh
you guys look good should we just do
mission one um
we go select mission go to that's all we
got no you can play these in any order
you want um
classify no like yeah press like x on it
it'll say all right so which one you
want to play then
i don't remember the name [ __ ] just
yeah do that just so for the purpose of
this um do the
go down which one of these look nice to
you
oh that one looks insane
yeah i'm trying not to die
there's not much just build me a castle
go to uh in darkness or provocation one
of those is like these giant trees that
one has trees
that one is
head of
i used to take it too long i realized
that but i don't want to
down one more do it do do rise and fall
done
oh mary you're quite the smoker there
huh well
everyone smokes cigars in this campaign
really everyone it's the weirdest motif
but they're all over the place
independent statement they're not e-cigs
they're like straight up to back you
guys
before we kill all these people mecca
nudes they're everywhere it's crazy
they're giant cigars too i need a bat
for my e-cig
it's not good for you but you really
don't want those years anyway
no
those are the bad years are you
encouraging
me yeah i mean like the way i see it is
like
you know
your grandchildren aren't visiting you
and no no oh you're eating pudding every
day like i'd rather just go out pudding
if i'm ever a grandpa i feel like my
kids are going to be my grandkids will
be smoking okay
so what's i have some wow what's going
on here so yeah this is the safe house
you get loadouts and do all that before
missions oh so this is my this is my our
bedrooms
oh we've gotta hunt them down oh so
these are cyber cores these are things
that
i don't have any fabrication kits right
oh look at this
this is insane we don't customize your
cybernetic modifications okay so
currently i don't have anything right
great i can choose i can choose my
gender just by coming in and out of
closet
okay cool it's the future all right uh
let's just let's just keep going i think
we should just deploy yeah let's go next
mission over at the store
oh nope
okay i guess we go in one at a time what
happens back there i never know what
they're doing
back there
well i just know that rob keeps going
into closets and coming out a woman
it's kind of my thing
all right so we're going to narnia
whatever
i don't even know what i picked but i'm
sure we'll be picking up weapons on the
battlefield i'll snipe uh overview
great
glad you put your helmet on
i'm i'm pretty glad too let's do that
because oh the twin helmets are cool and
you ain't cool
unless you got a helmet on what nah i'm
all gears of war style so this is heavy
chest filled out no helmet
yeah it's too far in the future though
they haven't like they haven't figured
it out there
it's different oh what's going on here
compromise allied operations
so this is the beginning of harry potter
so
we're on our own
we know taylor's looking for the
surviving members of the black project
a lot of smoke is awesome christopher
maloney is in the campaign uh you might
know him as the dude from law and order
or
my favorite uh gene the chef from wet
hot american summer ramsay station i'm
gonna go found all my sweaters
territories so you guys i'm gonna go
hump a fridge
no i said i've got a fondue some
cheddars i'm gonna do some cheddar for
dinner there's gonna be a lot of them
so what they what they say
there's there's a story
i guess uh
i can't talk about too much more i don't
know
let's just play it there's a story
we don't want a game here
body bags oh that guy has a lot of
cleaning to do we're always on trains
it's like that movie trainspotting
it's like that movie
about the
train hey hey
you still with us
yeah just
zoned out for a second there
not a bad idea
i think we just traded one bad situation
for another
okay glad i'm not the only one feeling
good
we are fighting a losing battle
the information taylor released helped
the nrc target strategic weak points in
the egyptian military defenses
all right
they are getting territory fast
civilian casualties are high
on the brink of so when you run out of
graveyards you just put photos on
stairwells
let's hope this doctor character talks
fast and gives us something useful
you will you don't hide out in cairo
unless you're really trying to run away
from something
that is a [ __ ] up teddy bear
you've seen better days
lieutenant khalil
you were told you were coming
i have your prisoner
i appreciate your help
especially as we're not exactly on the
books can't walk past them good to see
you so very action-packed
reinforcements
drones robots munitions
see you guys later
you guys chose the wrong stairs dude
slow down
someone's pushing i can't walk
slow down dude your prisoner may have
vital the men responsible for the nrc oh
cool it's like a little shopping mall
if we apprehend them
we'll be able to ensure more support
that's doing all right
that's a polite way kind of malls do you
go to
you want help
the cool kind where there's dudes on
stretchers to secure dr saleem before
the nrc advance
i warn you
rob that's those aren't malls you're
going to that's just the morgue don't
worry
whoa
his foot's gone you're operational he's
pretty tight
we have less than a thousand men this
guy's got a lot of cleaning to do
squadron
good luck essential supplies are low now
you're still holding on you can thank
raul menendez what oh will they play
feeding him
that looks like a really uncomfortable
position all right you get everything up
uh the dude who
hendrix he swears like too much
this guy is this dude
awesome [ __ ] stop
dude
you'll be all right
dude was freaking out
are these like
ammo here okay cool yeah it's ammo
resupply
thank you for your cooperation
lieutenant
appreciate it
doesn't hear the pain how slow am i
proning
guys let's try to look professional
oh we sped up let's go upstairs all
right open the doorbell
oh
i do not know or care
but you are holding me without cause
and i demand to speak to a legal
i'm just going to avoid any spoilers
good call
i told you
all right
this is a
adult
all right look at how wait wait wait
wait turk you run like yeah
dude
everyone runs stupid give me a runway
strip let's go
come on guys sporting louis vuitton
you guys look so good i think it's
because of the robot legs i'm following
you
oh
oh some [ __ ] is going down
oh dude you're [ __ ] gone he's fine
you're gonna dart on your neck we're
gonna get you out of here ooh
let's party
uh
watch out for the wraps
now there goes them all
jamba juice
do we treat robots or in five minutes
this place is becoming a starbucks so at
this point the campaign if you don't
just unlock all the missions you usually
have cyber a lot of cybernetic powers
and you can kind of control the robots a
little bit or just like light them on
fire
but right now oh look at this guy oh i
could have probably could have saved him
yeah just shoot them
oh they take a few more bullets
but third
third oh god i'm down
you got him one of those rolling meat
orbs killed me
i'm going high i'm gonna try to get some
high ground
a little turret action here
let's flank them oh i'm on a turret i
think everything's dead though
oh they're coming out of that crate
there's a lot coming out of that crate
good job
uh so can i change my
so right now it looks like i have a
power up can i change that
it's like it looks like someone's
jumping what does that do
that is your uh that's your jump
no i'm talking about r1 l1 bottom right
where does that power up
i don't know it's that's just
[ __ ] what is it oh so press right okay
is it a speed do i speed boost press
right on the d-pad and then
right on the d-pad sorry right on the
d-pad is your x-ray vision you can keep
it on all the time it shows people
um isn't there a way to like change the
power
whoa yeah hold down
hold hold down hold down the d-pad it'll
it it's not an active that's a passive
ability but i guess i can't do it right
now but okay
yeah
wow i'll just even go
what i want to get in the car
[ __ ] did you all go
get in
okay
okay what the [ __ ]
are you guys all in truck to get in the
back of me trying to find where you even
went hey you're with me
yeah we don't have any powers unlike
right now that's just a passive one
we would but
okay
so later on we have the ability to like
because i know there's like you know
there's like sonic
there's like a sonic power up that makes
people throw up or something yeah there
are ones that affect humans there are
some that affect robots there's some
that you can take control of drones the
vomit one is really really weird it is
weird it's it's cool at first but then
yeah
it makes people throw up
um i think it's a loading screen that's
hidden
so there's a treyarch logo this is black
ops
this is about halfway through the
campaign
this is something they've shown off a
lot
um
but it's
it's great to actually play it
for player
yeah so it's uh
the campaign
uh took me like seven hours it's
actually pretty long for a call of duty
um yeah that's pretty long for co-op
they
they throw in a lot of these tougher
enemies which just take a lot of bullets
to kill
and obviously there are more enemies
but they had to like exponentially
increase the difficulty because there's
four people
the spike launchers are used to demolish
buildings we plan to use it we're in
egypt cairo
well dropped before we can get the truck
into position oh chill out
for once i say stick to plan a okay so
we have this
spike gun that we have to
shoot bombs into the concrete too
so yeah to equip the power up and you
press the left on the d-pad
so where do we want these things oh this
gun is sick um don't don't
yeah actually nevermind
right on your d-pad it'll bring up like
the black ops 3 vision thing
it'll show you where people are oh wow
and like what type of person they are if
i can see it then you guys will see the
person too
got it
oh that's
friendly
so there are definite let me get some
high ground here snipes
did someone put the spike in that i did
in one of them did you detonate it i did
okay
i'll get the next one
i'm trying to see where they all are
okay i can do this one uh
press the left with it left i'm gonna
flip it
did you get him yeah i'm getting them
all right good
yes
oh you have to go up to it
i think i finally fired oh i'm being
really dumb
come on get me again yeah hold on i'm
not gonna go down there until some of
that stuff is dead
all right i'm gonna die too trying to
get you again
i'm not paying attention
oh hey what's up yeah i can tell
we need to get rid of other snipers can
you guys come revive us
yeah i'm getting sniped we're behind
some cover here it's all right i'll
eventually get to mary
are you crawling to me yeah i'm out
sorry this is a dangerous time i'm out
i'm coming
[ __ ] robots oh so we have a reason
i'm going
just get away run away
we're back i'm dead come back
can anyone get me
anyone else down i got married you
all right so where's the next one it's
over there on the left but that's where
everyone dies
you take your time see this
is this is the co-op campaign there's a
lot of people
[ __ ]
i down myself
all right it looks a little clear i'm
gonna go try
all right i'm gonna try to cover you
yeah i can cover you
what's the detonation they really just
keep coming yeah i'm out of ammo too
damn it if someone can ride me i have a
spike there oh no it did it worked i
just got down though oh man i just got
down dude that's rough
well
oh i just got down too sick
uh oh damn we failed wow there are a lot
of enemies co-op
all right what we got checkpoint yeah i
just gotta spike it if we all want to
come to the left side and cover i can go
get that
i can do the spike
dude
take it out quick where are you i'm on
the ledge to the left
i'm going
yeah there's another i think there's one
more
oh there's drones
war of the future
where are you
i'm back
i'm trying to get as back as i can
there's two more there's a lot of stuff
to the left
wait does that not revive you no didn't
go all the way
oh yeah there's one right here
i got it i got i got it you just can't
move when you're reviving which is kind
of dumb but
oh [ __ ]
[ __ ]
hendricks is just like leave the
swearing to me
all right all right there's one right
here yeah
go got you covered all right
done
running i'm gonna blow it up
okay one more
thing one more all right
i see it
it's way up there
sure
i'll move up on the left
or no it's on the right sorry right it's
on the right behind this wall i could
probably get to it
you i'm going to go for it uh yeah go
watch out for the wraps oh [ __ ] raps
i got him all right i got it i got it i
got it i'm running i'm running
nice
switch guns you'll run
faster back behind the wall oh god i'm
not gonna make it yeah everybody go back
to where we
i'm gonna crawl to you you guys leave me
i'll crawl
um we can probably get you yeah all
right
just clear those oh no i'm dying
i just got killed i should have left
[ __ ] i'm just gonna go i'm just gonna
just to complete him gonna go to rob do
it
rob you wanna i'm gonna be here
now
get up buddy
no come on buddy
thanks
sorry mary
don't worry it's not like i
planted the last charge or anything
hey
died for a great cause i did
don't you forget that
for my country
oh look at it
what were you thinking oh my god i need
to change guns i can't run for [ __ ]
oh yeah
we should blow this up oh should we
gotta get up there
i got it
about
eric i think you should get back there
or what happened we detonated okay we
detonated
there's a problem
what now
i got it
that's weird
oh
that'll do it
what's the problem
up
got possessed
done
whoa
okay
so weird to hear cheering after so many
people have died
got their intestines ripped up
they're looking for another way into
ramses
secure the area lieutenant will
rendezvous understood
if i do a new loadout up here
yeah i want to change it up as well good
call
wait i think
emerald
are you okay
okay so you can change your cyber court
here
yeah but we don't i don't think we have
any unlocks
cause we started this mission you if you
start beginning you unlock more
he's the villain
um
he's just the person
he's a member of the black ops squad
dropping down there
moving up
move along
are you supposed to fall down there
there's snipers
snipers yeah oh i got that
drones
oh throw that back
grenade
get
i ready pick up any any weapons
it doesn't seem that way
they're biometrically sealed apparently
that's what's good that's what makes
sense they say that just like
do they really say that it's like the
first mission yeah just like tickets to
disneyland
there's like mini tanks watch out
all right so should i i should be able
to control these like
oh whoa grenade
like where's their ro i should be able
to control like a drone right i think i
have like the if you have that uh
ability
i forget what the
button is
bro
oh what
oh you know this guy here well i uh i
feel pretty quick i'm down
what's the password i'm on my way
already yes
look at you
all of that teamwork we're shooting you
actually thought you're a bad guy oh you
stupid helmet did you uh that's your
stupid helmet
my helmet is badass you're wrong
hey give me a name
okay
over there huh whoa
one
two
three hurt there's a park coming up that
takes about half an hour
do we want to get into that or end it
after this cutscene anything else
we should probably end it probably under
the next part
step in there cool
i want to see what happens yeah
i think they i think they've showed this
one before winslow back down
friendly friendly friendly i want to see
that movie again
like behind enemy lines
yeah
what is that
wilson yeah
before he was owen wilson yeah
dude looks a lot like hendrix help me
please
i feel like
i don't want to alarm you
but you got something stupid okay let me
figure out what's wrong and then
oh
get out of there
[ __ ]
why does this scene look
super reminiscent to like
is it from the last one too no i've
showed this before like it this is
this next part is the part they've shown
and it takes a while especially with
four players gotcha
seems kind of clear
brad well we'll probably wrap it up
there then yeah
great
thank you guys for joining us to see
some call of duty black ops 3 both
zombie mode and the campaign with four
player online co-op
uh there's obviously a lot more teamwork
that could go into this there's a lot of
there's a lot more to see we basically
like barely scratched the surface but
that's a good first look at it so um
when can you get this
e this releases in the us
like midnight tonight tonight tomorrow
it's really specific right yeah pacific
time yeah well
if you want to get this game no matter
what time's on you're at midnight
tonight it'll
be ready to release um we'll have our
review up
soonish like tonight tonight once in
australia new zealand uh 9pm okay yeah
so we want to make sure servers are
working all day but um
yeah
all right my full opinion up later on so
come back to check it out yeah so 9pm
for the review and midnight if you want
to play so thank you guys for joining us
and we'll see you next time
you